what's the deal with airplane
peanuts Bobby Lee has an extensive
comedic acting background dating all the
way back to his first ever movie role in
1999 as Chinese man I did the
underground comedy movie that for a
decade they they put did advertisements
late at night on Comedy Central and I
was in those advertisements I had got a
lawyer get out of it to get out of it oh
my God cuz he paid me 50 bucks but up to
this point there's been very few serious
or dramatic acting roles on Bobby's
resume outside of some improv on bad
friends and this impromptu scene with
Andrew Santino on
flagrant my
son I love you so much and I got to tell
you the only heart that you can have is
mine thank you Daddy but I'm not going
to give it to you what
the because there's so many other
Koreans I can
buy what the [__] even though he often
in downplays his acting career being
considered a legitimate actor seems like
something Bobby Lee takes very seriously
despite his offscreen Antics and
wildcard reputation in Hollywood but I
call that the Korean hello it's a
cultural thing I understand you
attempted to make that case but the
employer didn't employer didn't see it
that way well it was early like it was
early in the morning I didn't know who
she was she was a new actress on the
show you needed to say hello I wanted to
welcome her to the show in a cultural
way and you you knew she was a player
she was in the in the team now no I
didn't know you didn't even know she'
been I didn't know who she was and she
was sitting there eating yogurt in my my
gut said fart in her mouth mhm It's Your
Instinct right my instin inact and your
cultural cultural it was a survival
Instinct even though he might be a
handful to work with at times Bobby Le
has played a role in dozens of famous
comedies such as Pineapple Express the
dictator and Curb Your Enthusiasm in
fact Bobby has 89 TV and movie credits
on IMDb which is quite impressive to
think he's been able to be a part of
that many different projects while
maintaining a thriving standup and
podcasting career but in order to make
the real jump from standup comedian to
movie star comedian it's crucial to
demonstrate the ability to play a lead
role in more than just comedy projects
and that's been a big hole in Bobby's
acting resume until now in a short film
titled death and ramen that came out
last week Bobby Lee Stars alongside Matt
Jones AKA Badger from breaking bad as
the main character in maybe the most
dramatic role Bobby has ever
filmed holy [__] get off me don't get me
wrong Bobby has plenty of funny moments
in this film as well but seeing him as
an actor in this serious light was a
super interesting experience what was
even more interesting however was
getting a chance to talk with the writer
and director of this film tiger G so
right off the bat Bobby Leah shared
dozens of insane stories from trouble
that he can get into working on movies
and TV shows over the years so after
creating this film with Bobby is he as
crazy as people say and do you have any
funny stories from his time on set you
know it was really interesting because I
had expected there to be some separation
from Bobby the Persona on stage and uh
on screen and who he is in real life
that guy is the whole package you know
he as wonderful and and insane in person
as he is uh as a Persona there's a
little bit of farting there's a but but
surprisingly he was incredibly like kind
to to his crew and and me like there's
something quite fatherly about him too
there's a lot of like interesting
stories uh to how we got to set though
we met over Korean barbecue uh before we
decided to shoot the movie you know he
shows up like 15 minutes late and and
and like he wa he's like 5 foot4 right
he comes in but the whole room like uh
in Korean barbecue restaurant kind of
just stops and and they stare at him and
we sit down and before we make it to our
table he like grabs me by the shoulder
he turns me around he goes I'm paying
today and then he takes home the takeout
you know so it's like that's like Bobby
in in a nutshell well we've all seen
Bobby as a hilarious comedic actor but
in death and ramen there's some more
serious scenes and tones how would you
rate him as a dramatic actor real fast
before tiger answers that question we
got to hear a quick word from the
sponsor of today's video I love watching
sports especially when I'm making money
and that's where today's sponsor
Underdog fantasy comes in Underdog is is
the easiest way to play fantasy sports
not just football you can make picks on
baseball basketball hockey UFC and more
it's simple just pick whether you think
a player stats will be higher or lower
and you can make big money right now
Underdog is giving new users a special
offer for Kenny picket higher or lower
than one yard I'm going over on auk and
metf receiving and mcaffrey rushing
Underdog pium games are available in 30
plus States including California Texas
and even Canada all you have to do is
click the link below or download
Underdog via the App Store and use code
joke world that's Underdog fantasy promo
code joke world for a first deposit
match up to $100 it makes watching the
NFL even more interesting for me so make
your own picks and rep your own team
with Underdog I think he's the best I
think that a lot of comedians um tend to
have like a real feel for tragedy and
drama but aren't necessarily given the
space to do so I think that Bobby
historically has you know he's been on
Mad TV and he's played a lot of
stereotypical characters kind of to be a
supporting character and to be the butt
of the joke I was ins ired to cast him
in a more dramatic role that still
utilized his you know very funny and
comedic chops but I was inspired when I
saw the 300th episode of tiger belly
where over the course of that episode
you know he was so vulnerable and open
uh with his friend David Cho and Steven
Yun and it just sort of introduced me to
a version of Bobby that I hadn't seen
before it was a version that was very
sensitive and kind of dark you you
always knew that there was Darkness
that's there but the vulnerability felt
fresh to me and that's when I knew knew
that uh he had what it took to to do it
and just was never offered the the
platform you were inspired from the
episode of tiger belly but being 21
years old making a movie with Bobby Lee
and Matt Jones from Breaking Bad has to
be kind of a surreal experience
regardless of how talented you are they
don't know that at the beginning did the
star power of these actors add any
pressure or were you able to just
operate business as usual I definitely
was not able to operate business as
usual there was a lot of push and pull I
like to do lot of rehearsals and and you
know we didn't have the leage to have
Bobby like come in for all those
rehearsals because he was already coming
in for like a lot of overnight shoots it
helped that Bobby and Matt uh who plays
Badger and Breaking Bad and plays death
in my film it helped that they were
friends prior to to to filming and that
was a total coincidence um I had no idea
I just casted each of them separately
and they knew each other from like years
ago and so that really helped that they
could sort of entertain each other and
be like each other's friends along the
way because it was a really tough
grueling shoot I would say that it was
like a process of like kind of proving
myself to to these actors who have
really been around the block and I do
think though it's somehow helped me a
little bit too being so young you know
there's a kind of like interesting
Mystique around it of you know they
don't know what I'm capable of I could
just be like a total phony but also you
know could be capable of more it was
like just the big question mark to them
until until the end of the shoot well
tiger thank you so much for your time
today do you have any closing statements
what should the people know about this
film about yourself about Bobby where
can they find it anything else you want
to throw out there yeah the film's
available now on on YouTube for North
American territories we'll be doing like
some interviews and um announcements
very soon but you I really hope you
enjoyed this movie it's certainly a
funny film but it's not a laugh out loud
film it's as sad as it is funny it's as
sensitive as it is you know quirky and
for the for the film fans uh you know we
love to see comedians kind of like step
out outside their comfort zone and do
something different guest spots from
last week The Joe Rogan Experience
talked with Kim conden and Sarah wine
shank whiskey Ginger talked with Miss
Pat Ralph barboso was a guest on tiger
belly Ralph also visited your mom's
house areu garbage had on Big J oakerson
flagrant did not have a guest two bears
one cave was Burton Tom Tom and Bert
Sebastian was on Chrissy chaos tastebuds
and stuff Island battled Donuts versus
crumb cake versus raspberry twists Nick
Mullen and Louis J Gomez were on the Tim
Dylan show Tim Dylan was on Matt and
Shane secret podcast Tim was also on
kill Tony as well as we might be drunk
different kind of bird you're like this
is like a weird it's a weird group it's
a weird group but you I'm I'm into it
they're very different even though they
look similar in a way but it's off there
was a show called Sliders in the 9s I
remember that Jerry o time Trel and
Sliders was and Louis kind of took about
Australia like this too where you you're
there and you're like it's almost our
world right and then Lou says oh like a
weird power I'll fly by so sliders was
just they would kept trying to get back
to their world and every time they'd
slide into another some of them would
obviously not be theirs like it would be
like dinosur but then some of them you'd
be like oh this is our world and then
it's like somebody's like head would
like do a full 360 go oh we're
not wow slider boy you're always talking
about
food this past weekend with theovon
spoke with stavos stavi was also on
first date hey babe posted the best of
2023 Weird Al was on the Block podcast
samarel visited stav's World Kyle dunan
was on take your shoes off being inan
with Jordan welcom steo Jeremiah Watkins
was on you know what dude Ari shafir was
on the Legion of skang the Honeydew
talked with Rob Riggle Steph Tov was on
only fans and Paulie Shore was on the
Harland Highway as far as brand new
stand-up comedy specials that are either
out right now or coming out soon the big
one this week was Nick Mullen Year of
the Dragon which is a brand new hourong
standup special that you can find on the
Adam Friedland Show YouTube channel
sto's heest fat Rascal premiered today
on Netflix also out on Netflix is
verified standup a two-part comedy show
filled at Webster Hall in New York
featuring Rising comedians such as
nimish Patel doce Salone and Rose but
Baker also Ali sadique released an hour
and 25 minute standup special titled
don't judge a book by its cover over on
his YouTube channel also out on YouTube
is Chad Daniels mixed reviews and Katie
Bole I'll do it myself which was
recorded live at New York comedy club
and a few specials in the works right
now that will be coming out soon
Adrienne AAP palushi just got done
recording her next standup special at
the comedy seller Brad Williams starfish
will come out on his website December
21st which is also the shortest day of
the year and not technically a standup
special but Tom sagora Matt R Marlin
wayin and Sam Jay just all sat down for
a Roundtable discussion about comedy as
a whole on the variety channel that a
lot of Comedy fans might be interested
in watching other than that we just came
out with the first ever line of joke
World merch last week for all the loyal
subscribers that have been asking for
more ways to support the channel there's
tons of good stuff on there from hoodies
and shirts to hats and mugs so if you
want to take a look the link is in the
description of this video and from now
until Christmas we will be donating one
item of food to a local food bank for
every item sold thank you for
watching joke
world that's did it joke
world and the world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out